[Music]
we have had a good look at the concept
of tissues so how do we define them yes
in simple words tissues are a group of
similar cells performing the same
function we have also taken a look at
the fact that tissues in plants and
animals are completely different
on one hand plants require two types of
tissues ones which are constantly
dividing and the others which have
attained maturity and do not divide
further on the other hand in case of
animals we have tissues which grow only
to a certain extent and then mature and
perform the same single function
throughout their lives they are all well
synchronized to work with proper
division of labor so now let's have a
quick glance at these tissues found in
both plants and animals beginning with
plant tissues first we classify them
based on the dividing and non-dividing
nature the ones that constantly divide
throughout the life of plants are called
the meristematic tissues these help in
the growth of plants in various ways
depending upon the location we classify
meristematic tissues as apical meristem
lateral meristem and intercalary
meristem the next in the list would be
those tissues which have lost the
capacity to divide these are the
permanent tissues these tissues help the
plant to perform various activities but
don't contribute to its growth we can
classify them further depending upon the
cells present in them first category is
where we have all the cells to be of the
similar type these are the simple
permanent tissues according to their
functions they are classified into three
types firstly parenchyma that acts as a
filler it sometimes gets modified to
have air cavities and is called the Eren
coma or maybe it can have chlorophyll
integrated which makes up the chlorine
coma located in the green parts of the
plant next in the list is the Tilottama
which works to give flexibility to
plant and lastly we have the
sclerenchyma that functions to give
rigidity and strength to the plant after
these simple tissues we move on to the
complex tissues here we have the
vascular bundle system that takes up the
responsibility of transportation so for
transporting water and minerals in only
the upward direction we have the xylem
xylem is made up of four major
components tracheids vessels xylem
parenchyma and die limb fibers similarly
for the transport of food we have the
phloem to help the plant it has also
made up of four major types of cells
that is the sieve tubes companion cells
phloem parenchyma and phloem fibers the
most unique characteristic of phloem is
that it can pass the substances in both
the directions well this was a general
idea about the various tissues found in
plants now let's have a look at the
tissues found in animals in animals we
categorized the various tissues based on
the major collective function so the
four major functions include protection
or covering connection movement and
locomotion and transmission of signals
accordingly we have the major types of
epithelial tissue connective tissue
muscular tissue and nervous tissue the
different types of epithelia include
simple squamous epithelia stratified
squamous epithelium columnar epithelia
cuboidal epithelium and lastly glandular
epithelium similarly various types of
connective tissues include bones
cartilage ligaments tendons areola
adipose and also blood next in this list
is the muscular tissue which consists of
three major types that is the striated
muscles all striated or smooth muscles
and the cardiac muscles and lastly we
have the nervous tissue that is made up
of magical cells called the neurons
these are responsible for
putting the signals in the form of
electrical impulses all these together
work in a synchronized manner and help
us perform the various functions
efficiently
[Music]